this is America in shutdown day 21 well
tonight as Christians begin Holy Week
and as Jews prepare to celebrate the
Passover we are all acutely aware of the
darkness that this kovat 19 crisis is
wrought the more than 10,000 Americans
who've now lost their lives and
countless more have had their lives
upended business is frozen parents
frustrated children are just confused
and workers unemployed but there are
some and we needed these hopeful signs
emerging now while New York is still
suffering greatly with its more than
4,700 Cova deaths the daily numbers are
actually stabilizing and there are other
positive signs total number of
hospitalizations are down the ICU
admissions are down and the daily
intubations are down those are all good
signs and again would suggest a possible
flattening of the curve earlier than
some people thought perhaps we'll be
watching well the West Coast is far
ahead of New York and the good news
category things are looking up in the
fight against Kovan both in Washington
State and in California now some states
are just doing such a good job at
budgeting and reallocating their own
resources that they're able to share
some of their medical equipment governor
jay Inslee a Democrat and now Sunday
that Washington state will be returning
more than 400 veteran leaders that it
received from the strategic national
stockpile so they can then be
transferred to other states and on
Saturday Oregon's governor Kate brown
she announced that her state can afford
to share a hundred and forty ventilators
with New York do you look at most places
where that you can call it the bump you
could go up the hill you can go up the
mountain you can go out whatever you
want to do it it's very flat do they
have a couple of tough ones New Jersey's
been very tough in New York has been
very tough you look at so many of these
states how well they're doing well
that's good to hear and like you I'm
wondering when do we get our country
back
will we truly get back to normal in this
country before there's an actual vaccine
that's available to everybody if back to
normal means acting like that never was
a coronavirus problem I don't think
that's gonna happen until we do have a
situation where you can completely
protect the population when we get back
to normal we will go back gradually to
the point where we can function as a
society that I mean if you want to get
to pre corona virus you know that might
not ever happen well the president
didn't seem like he was completely
thrilled with that answer I think we can
get more than back to normal from an
economic sample it actually be better
but more than back to normal but I I
would agree that would love to see a
vaccine but immediately would love to
see a therapeutic and I think we're
getting very close now speaking of
therapeutics some in the media and the
medical establishment as I mentioned to
Sean continue this bizarre assault on
the decades-old drug hydroxychloroquine
that's being used by doctors worldwide
and I mean worldwide to treat kovat
patients especially seeing promise in
early intervention intervention now to
get a sense of how political the
criticism has become check this out
we're focusing so much on
hydroxychloroquine we're overlooking all
the really important social issues that
are not being mentioned we're not
talking about the spike and domestic
violence that's being seen by people you
know being forced to say inside we're
not talking about the impact on
indigenous and undocumented communities
all throughout the US and we're not
talking enough about the impact of
coronavirus on people of color well not
to say those aren't all important issues
they are but you can talk about all of
those things can we not and what he
didn't say is that the hydroxy plus
azithromycin is now being used by
physicians treating kovat patients in
his own Hospital I know because I've
spoken to the doctors now I'll say what
I said was every day if at all possible
short of a vaccine we need a cheap
scalable therapeutic but remember the
drug companies they don't make their
real money off old generic drugs no no
so far we have a
old study in China albeit on the small
side we have a study by one of Europe's
top epidemiologists Didier Rowe and we
have observational data from around the
globe that shows that hydroxy and as if
throw can drop a kovat patients viral
load and send them home from the
hospital so they drop the viral load
they will not shed that virus as much as
they would without it now Andrew Cuomo
is even seeing the promise we've allowed
usage of the hydroxychloroquine with the
zero minus pax pack in hospitals at
their discretion the federal government
is going to increase the supply to New
York pharmacies
there has been an atonal evidence that
it is promising that's why we're going
ahead doctors have to prescribe it
anecdotally it's been positive
well another hotspot is acknowledging
the benefits as well these drugs don't
represent a silver bullet or a magic
wand however many medical doctors have
chosen to prescribe these drugs to
relieve symptoms of the virus in some
patients positive results in a patient
by these drugs could potentially allow
our ventilator needs to decrease of
course that's a la attorney-general by
Louisiana Attorney General
well of course nothing short of a
vaccine is a magic wand but the drugs
can relieve pressure on the hospitals in
the icy use helping us to avert a total
collapse of our healthcare system which
was the whole point of flattening the
curve in the first place saving patients
and saving the hospitals now finally
there's an interesting new poll by just
the news polling and Scott Rasmussen on
what worries Americans most about the
crisis thirty percent of Americans say
the most difficult impact has been on
their loss of income 27 percent cite
finding supplies 23 percent chose
isolation in boredom only 4% of
Americans cited their health as their
top concern
I was thinking about that I think people
are just pragmatic they know there are
risks to walking out the door every day
they want to be careful they want to be
you know have common sense
but they know that we must protect the
vulnerable including health care workers
first responders they get all that yet
they also know that this situation of
being locked in shut in is just not
sustainable they know that every day
we're in shutdown is another day of
self-inflicted devastating wounds to
American families and to our country as
a whole if we want to finish this war we
have to get back to work
we don't want to be doing this for
months and months and months with an
open our country again this country
wasn't meant for this but we have to
open our country again we need an
American resurrection sooner rather than
later and those are my thoughts at the
end of day 21 America in shutdown